[Music]
time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio big stories in the
national football league and the biggest
story right now by far
that epic monday night football game
between the baltimore ravens and the
cleveland browns the
victory by baltimore how do we feel
about
both of these teams moving forward and
peter let's start with the ravens who
are eight and five but still technically
on the outside looking in
in the effort to win the seventh seed in
the afc do you
think they can parlay this victory into
a playoff berth
i think they'll make the playoffs mike i
think the biggest
issue now going forward is
whether i mean look they have absolute
zero depth at quarterback
and you know obviously they have to help
hope that
lamar jackson can hang in there you know
because what are they going to do
if he doesn't obviously they'll sign
somebody uh
and and they'll have a backup but their
only hope i think is if lamar jackson
can
obviously play the rest of the way i
think the one other
issue if i'm baltimore that i'm a little
concerned about right now
is just the simple fact that they
really are even though they put up 47
points or 45 plus two whatever
you want to call it you know they are so
reliant now
in my opinion on lamar jackson and his
legs
um you know their passing game i thought
i forget i think it might have been
brian greasy on the broadcast who said
this team needs a receiver i mean a very
disappointing game from marquis brown
despite the late touchdown
um you can't drop as many i mean what is
it about
great receivers or people who you
thought were great receivers who all
have the dropsies now
i mean it's incredible everybody on
pittsburgh is dropping them
and last night marquise brown he'll
either get credit for two or three drops
and the game might have been changed
permanently
you know if marquise brown catches that
ball from
uh mcsorley late in the game it might
not have required all the late heroics
but
you know so much pressure now on lamar
jackson
to be mr everything for baltimore
we hear all the time about these gloves
the technology that makes them so tacky
and if you've ever tried them they are
incredible
makes it even more amazing when
professional athletes who are paid to
catch footballs can't catch footballs
with the assistance of those gloves and
that's what made
the catch by marquis brown and the
touchdown that
that put the ravens ahead late uh so
much more memorable because
when it went in his direction the first
thing i thought is this guy is going to
drop it but you're absolutely don't drop
it bar jackson
that has become the focal point of that
offense and you're putting too many eggs
in that basket especially if he has to
run to the locker room and put something
in a basket or
or have cramps whatever cleveland browns
the cleveland browns uh even though they
lost and i know kevin stefanski the
coach of the team said after the game
peter there are no moral victories i
expect every coach to say that
they have to feel good about the last
two weeks they have shown they can
compete with the best teams in the
league
yes but all i know is that
you know look they've given up 38 38
and 47 points in three games to their
division rivals
so i would be more on the side of
uh stefanski after that game last night
than anything else and look they played
valiantly and
and baker mayfield played valiantly you
know they are a
really good competitive team
but i mean their defense
three games huge games it's
is it's been a track meet you know mike
look
to average giving up 41 points a game
in your three biggest division games of
the year
it's not sustainable so you know look
you can look at the browns and say man
galleon gallon effort uh valiant play
all that stuff but
it's just you can't you can't last
playing with a defense like that
look i agree with you completely the
problem is uh and i guess this is a good
thing for the browns it's not like
there's a lot of great defense being
played anywhere else which could serve
them well they are destined to make it
to the playoffs it'll be interesting to
see what
they do there that's it for this edition
of pft on yahoo sports thanks for some
of your time
we'll see you again down the road
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports